copyright trolls are ruining YouTube Not
only is the video transformative because
we made edits to it but it's literally
me it's me talking to Andrew Tate these
corporate mercenaries don't seem to
believe in a little thing called fair
use and because some of the biggest
players on these platforms have hired
them they've been able to do a lot of
damage now not only is this messed up
but it's also illegal in many countries
so the question is will YouTube do
anything to stop this and can they
[Music]
so for a while this mysterious company
was sending copyright claims to anyone
that covered popular YouTubers like I
show speed this meant losing the ad
money from the video itself which in
some cases was multiple millions of
views or instead risking a copyright
strike by fighting the claim in court so
these claim notifications did point to a
company name but when people looked it
up there wasn't that much to figure out
so the riddles only clue might be the
thing that you remember from when this
whole issue resurfaced earlier this year
thumb media but let's just take a look
at this recent tweet from feudiv so that
we can you know examine how one of these
claims actually works and this one is
from thumb media a video of few divs
2v2ing Aiden Ross was copyright claimed
by thumb media affiliate so a copyright
claim like this means that the video
stays up it's just that whoever claimed
the copyright just takes the money from
the video in question so if you you want
to contest the claim you can and there
are absolutely valid reasons in a legal
sense to use content that originated
elsewhere in your own video ultimately
YouTube is not the one making the call
on these claims what happens is there's
a process for them to communicate the
claim between the two parties and then
at a certain point it's on the person
making the claim to actually sue the
person that they claim is infringing on
the copyright so people like futives are
dealing with this issue now and they're
in a tough spot because if they choose
to contest this thing they have to give
their personal details to the claimant
so that they can be served a lawsuit if
they so choose so you can see for all of
the above reasons why people don't want
to contest these things lawsuits are
expensive and inconvenient and you're
risking serious damage to your channel
if you do contest it and you get a
copyright strike that stays on your
account permanently and again could
endanger in the future in feudu's case
they were lucky enough to be able to get
the claim rescinded shortly after
tweeting about the whole thing but
ultimately it shows that it's still
happening and it doesn't look like any
of this was an accident either as
YouTuber jabroni pointed out in March
these don't look like automated claims
it actually appears as if somebody is
just searching words like I show speed
or Aiden Ross going to videos that
contain any amount of those things and
claiming the copyright for them usually
when you get claimed on YouTube it's by
an automated system it's by Content ID
the copyright owner gets a list of
videos that are using the content that
they claim to own they can just go
through a check box and say claim claim
claim it's all on one screen the claims
we were getting last summer were manual
claims which means somebody was going to
our videos and manually clicking the
claim this video button so this thing
hit a fever pitch back in March around
the time that jabroni made that video
that I just showed you and in that
situation a lot of the uncertainty was
just around who are thumb media really
what's going on were these claims
actually made on behalf of ishow speed
and Aiden Ross or was this some other
kind of trolling like in the past when
people had re-uploaded old videos but
then claimed the original was infringing
on the copyright in the past speeds fans
tried to talk to him about what was
happening with thumb media was this
actually him what was going on really
and he gave them pretty much a
non-answer the first time
how do I stop this from happening like
because it's not happening to me but
about three months ago speed came out
and made a video where he admitted yeah
the media is working for me and please
stop sending YouTube emails about it
YouTube eggs y'all to stop spamming
about these emails
about the cardigan and the thumb media
affiliate that is me just wanted to let
y'all know everybody know that so which
I guys please stop thank y'all so speed
was either ashamed of what he was doing
and was hoping to kind of stay in the
background here or he believed that it
was very possible that thumb media would
just continue to take the Heap for him
into the foreseeable future but Aiden
Ross on the other hand didn't do that
instead he boasted about using claims
and Strikes to his own personal
Advantage W chat by the way this is um
Hassan's head moderator chat
I don't know who this person is I've
never met this person this person is not
my head moderator Chad we stole eight
thousand dollars from him W
he needed that yes yes
and he also went after Hassan for
footage that included Hassan debating
Andrew Tate like Hassan was a literally
in the video because like here I
destroyed Andrew Tate featuring Aiden
Ross and Hassan it's the same exact
video but on xqc's channel it's like
copy striking this you know what I mean
if he has ownership over this entire
call which he doesn't he would have to
[__] copy shark xcc as well which he
can't but it's the exact same thing
there are these recent examples sure but
if you go back you could find some
pretty old Reddit posts about thumb
media as well so this thing's been going
on for a little while it's not a new
problem but it is starting to become
more mainstream and there's more
awareness of it and even though I talked
about thumb media and cardigan in some
of these previous cases they aren't the
only people who are going around
claiming videos getting falsely
copyright striked by some group name
create network MGD they go around
claiming content that isn't theirs
reject any appeals and steal the revenue
from the videos I am quite literally
powerless to this form of theft because
YouTube won't protect its creators turns
out I'm not the only victim of this
copyright abuse so why do these claims
continue to happen happen listen I'm
sure some of the videos claimed probably
wouldn't meet a rigorous fair use
definition in corp or something like if
you're just stitching together Clips I
think that's certainly a gray area and
if there's no other transformation that
could make a core battle pretty hard
however I'm not a lawyer so yeah so many
of the videos that were claimed were
attempting to transform that content
through narrative or commentary that
there's no way it could be considered a
replacement for the original Source
material and even if we accept that it's
likely that most of these coffee rituals
will simply release the claims before
going to court that's still clearly an
attempt at intimidation people are
protective of their channels they see
them as potentially a future way to make
a living so threatening them directly
like that a lot of people will just say
I don't want to fight this claim it's
easier not to I also want to mention
that in many jurisdictions what they're
doing is illegal it's just that it's
pretty hard to get them to face Justice
for these sorts of things in the United
States false copyright claims are a
criminal offense that sadly only carries
a penalty of two thousand five hundred
dollars per claim even if the government
decides that there's a problem on
YouTube which seems unlikely without
YouTube itself advocating for some kind
of help it's hard to see how they would
collect and sort through all of these
claims with what they currently have now
as far as I can tell YouTube is
following existing law about how to
handle copyright claims the problem is
that there are people who are clearly
acting in bad faith so YouTube could act
to censure those entities if they wanted
to in some cases they've taken direct
action against accounts that repeatedly
issued false strikes like they did
against Christopher Brady in 2019 in
that case though it was alleged that
Brady tried to extort Channel
with the threat of a third strike and he
confessed to making false strikes as
part of the settlement still Brady did
have to do a lot including issuing
strikes not claims to get YouTube to
actually take action because the case
was settled and it wasn't part of the
statement the alleged extortion part of
the scheme remains unproven in a court
of law but despite YouTube being
generally slow to act on the copyright
claims trolls some people have tried to
take action the Electronic Frontier
Foundation is a non-profit organization
that has long supported the fight
against copyright trolls on the internet
they've even briefed the U.S House
Judiciary about this pressing issue and
about legislation that would make it
even easier for these trolls to operate
which they don't want in 2017 h3h3
Productions successfully fought off a
lawsuit from Bold guy AKA Matt ha Zone
after the latter attempted to sue H3
over a parody video that they had made
through all the grief all the all the
drama man now I'm so happy we did it
because this is a landmark case not just
for us
but seriously the wording that the judge
put into the opinion uh is gonna
strengthen fair use across YouTube the
process took a year and a half a lot of
money and frankly it's not something
that every YouTube channel would be able
to do H3 are pretty big but they did
fight this thing to the end and
critically got a judgment that
reinforced fair use as an idea on
YouTube any review of the Klein's video
leaves no doubt that it constitutes
critical commentary on haas's video
there is also no doubt that the Klein's
video is decidedly not a market
substitute for haas's video for these
and the other reasons set forth below
defend its use of the clips from the
Haas video constitute fair use as a
matter of law oh that makes me rock hard
dude I am fully chubbed why am I talking
about this it's not exactly like bold
guy or whatever was a copyright troll
although he did use the system in this
case to try and get a desired outcome
okay well the reason I'm talking about
it is because these copyright trolls
probably understand that actually taking
this thing to court is going to be
difficult in many many cases but these
companies like thumb media can simply
push the dispute until it's absolutely
the last moment to start legal action
and then just drop it which is what
happened to jabroni and Omni too after
reviewing your dispute some media
affiliate has decided to release their
copyright claim on your YouTube video
oh my God I was so relieved and I felt
like the weight of the world was like
taken off of my ass we found out that
this claim is invalid and have already
taken appropriate action on the relevant
reference the claim should be released
in the next 48 hours and even if it
seems likely these companies will back
down at the last moment it's still
unsettling to have someone try to
intimidate you this way if a video was
doing really well it's also keeping the
channel from collecting the proceeds
throughout the entire dispute so what
else can be done unless YouTube makes
some change to de-incentivize companies
from doing this I'm sure will keep
happening in fact I'm sure for every
case that we hear about on Twitter or
Reddit or something there's probably 29
of them where somebody just said okay
fine I'll just let the claim go I it's
not worth it to me so this business
model is probably working for people I
don't know if YouTube ultimately only
cares about the highest profile cases or
maybe that's all they have resources to
really address I'm not sure but their
position in Market terms is pretty
dominant right now however that can
change I really like the YouTube
platform but if we're going to let
powerful people trample up and coming
creators using intimidation tactics like
this
maybe the dominance of YouTube does
deserve to change a bit
yeah so I was late for the shoot this
morning I'm not kidding I know some of
you in the comments are gonna be like
that's [__] Josh but I'm not kidding
the reason was
I was taking my kids to school well to
daycare and I saw an old woman trying to
put a harness on a dog and the dog just
ran away and I was like are you gonna be
you gonna be good to get that dog and
she literally said I don't know it's
pretty fast it went about the dog went
about two blocks I would say and my kid
like my oldest kid like walked right up
to it like Drew in style and was just
like the dog was so chill and the woman
said that the dog was friendly and stuff
and so I was like okay okay
and then I she had like kind of stopped
the dog the dog was tired she was like
right next to it and I grabbed the
collar and it was like bro nah I think
it was just startled it didn't really
try to hurt me but yeah it was uh it was
a fun morning and I was like 15 minutes
late for my shoot and I helped the dog
and I helped the old woman so
and maybe I shouldn't say oh she was
just she was just uh she was an elder
you know she was a distinguished Elder
she wasn't an old woman